mara mara one piece of break Michael
Vick's we're back with Sunday if you're
able to do that as you're getting into
that game does that mean anything to you
you know like I said it might fit my
favorite Claire and for me to do such a
thing it's incredible and you know he
had every longtime it would be pretty
cool but you know focus on awareness
that's a Marv Jackson talking about the
opportunity that he has to set the
single-season rushing record for
quarterbacks he simply needs to add 64
yards to his current total to break
Michael Vick's 1039 yards from the 2006
season that was mixed last season with
the Falcons just months before they
found the dogfighting operation in rural
Virginia and look people like to compare
Lamar Jackson to Michael Vick Chris I I
believe that Jackson is better than Vick
and I know that the Jackson benefits
from an offense that was specifically
tailored to him well why the hell
haven't the Falcons specifically tailor
an offense to Mike Vick and here's the
theft the question hey what a tip hey
but if they would have tailored an
offense to Mike Vick he still would have
thrown the PlayBook in the backseat not
looked at it well my Vick relied up he
relied upon his god-given abilities when
in doubt run the ball run the ball run
the ball okay yes and runs the ball as
an opportunity not as a crutch well
you're right I won't disagree with you
there now yeah they tried to be no
Buddha with a square peg in a round hole
with Michael Vick they tried to make him
Tom Brady and Peyton Manning that was
wrong this is a team that you know had
the vision and that's where you know
again we just got to give the Ravens a
whole lot of credit and all the the
decision makers and everything around it
to go all in on this I mean that's where
it's special I think you know again I
don't know if he's as talented as
Michael Vick man Michael Vick was one of
those guys that it was third in 19 and I
was over there like he's gonna get it
he'll get the first down it doesn't
matter whether he runs or throw some
missile down the middle of the field he
was really really gifted but to your
point and I think you're exactly right
Lamar Jackson seems to have the big
picture and just a certain
professionalism about them and a
day-to-day detailed Ness
about him that is a little bit better
than Michael Vick there's no doubt about
that I mean just the things in the way
he handles himself in the press
conference the way he handles attention
to himself it always goes back to the
team and I want to win the Superbowl he
doesn't care about the MVP and I really
loved that about Lamar Jackson he's got
that patriot player brainwashing
innovation play for the Patriots right
it's not about me it's not about
anything it's not about the next
opponent it's about the next game gonna
win you know what don't I don't care
about the 49ers game we don't play the
49ers til next week we play the Rams
tomorrow night yeah it's just he's got
that attitude that that coaches love to
have and he puts in the work he's got
the incredible god-given abilities and
here he is on the cusp of setting the
single-season rushing record for
quarterbacks all right Baker Mayfield
and what a contrast because last year
Baker Mayfield was the guy who had
emerged as the top quarterback from the
class of 2018 now the guy who was the
last player taken in round one that year
Lamar Jackson has become the MVP
favorite Baker Mayfield still struggling
to find his way this season he is banged
up and he has a hand injure and he also
has rib injuries that popped up on the
injury report yesterday here he is
yesterday when he was asked about his
hands will be able to play mama didn't
raise a wuss
a couple of hand massages just your
casual everyday hand treatment he is as
funny as he was last year he's just not
as productive as he was and it makes me
wonder what the bigger issue is because
he played with the Handy you see a trap
there if you're watching on TV yeah but
but the ribs the ribs were the surprise
yesterday at one point the the team said
that they expected Baker Mayfield to
fully participate in practice without
limitations then it turned out he was
limited in practice and then when the
official injury report came out it had
both hand and ribs in the designation so
I don't know what the issue is here but
it bears watching they should be able to
beat the Bengals they play them twice
over the last four weeks they need to go
on a run here they need to have Baker
Mayfield healthy and he's gonna play
through it yeah there's one thing to
play throw it and be hampered or to be
able to play through it and be as
effective as you need to be yeah yeah
well we'll see where he's at first off I
mean come on mama didn't raise a voice
is that that's that's an all-timer I
love some of his lines he's he is very
fun to watch that way Hey with a hurt
hand that certainly can affect your
accuracy grip on the ball all those
things I can tell you where he got his
ribs hurt I mean he got he as he was
throwing he got hit right here a helmet
right where you're not protected as a
quarterback
TJ watt just absolutely crushed him oh
man I have some sweaty pits there too
that's not cool
thank you yes I just wanted to let
everybody know that but either way yes
he got crushed right there and that is
like a really tough spot I'm gonna punch
you there this weekend so you could see
how it feels but that'll affect your
throwing when you raise back to throw
and torque that shoulder and all that
listen I expect anything and everything
from you as I'm sitting as sitting there
trying to work on Sunday here comes Sims
with these big giant meat hooks it's
like the claw I feel like the stuffed
animal that's getting grabbed and pulled
and it did like digs into your skin weak
I'm kind of famous in my family for
doing that as
just I don't know but in your family
well you're in the family now footballs
family Florio we work together every day
alright one more real quick before we
leave take a break how about this
out of the blue yesterday chase
McLaughlin available on waivers the
kicker that replaced Robbie gold while
gold was injured for the 49ers
he gets waived on Tuesday the cults
claim him yes the cults the cults could
be ready to move on from Adam Vinatieri
an o Vinatieri all of a sudden has an
MRI on his knee and he's gonna be
meeting with the team today to figure
out the future this could be kind of a
graceful way Chris for the cults and
finitary to go their separate ways yeah
maybe I mean this could be like your Eli
Manning Danielle Jones convenient injury
theory again here but I know this was
surprising I didn't even see this until
this morning and then finitary goes back
to the Patriots how about that they
wanna kick
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports